O să îți vorbesc despre o minge care se rotește, cu excepția că nu e o minge și nu se rotește. Astăzi, în Qiskit în
clasă, vom vorbi despre această proprietate cuantică numită spin, privind experimentul care a găsit primele dovezi pentru
aceasta. Bun venit la Qiskit în clasă. În această serie, vom folosi Qiskit pentru a explora câteva concepte fundamentale acoperite de obicei
în cursuri legate de Quantum Computing. Fiecare videoclip va fi însoțit și de un modul interactiv
cu link în descrierea de mai jos, deci asigură-te că îl verifici. Astăzi vorbim despre experimentul Stern-Gerlach din 1922.
Este unul dintre cele mai cunoscute din istoria teoriei cuantice, deoarece demonstrează atât de clar cum funcționează spinul cuantic.
Dar nu asta au intenționat să arate Stern sau Gerlach. Experimentul a fost conceput pentru a testa un nou model cuantic
al atomului, numit modelul Bohr, după Niels Bohr, care l-a propus în 1913. În model, electronii se roteau în jurul
nucleului pe orbitale discrete și puteau trece între acele orbitale absorbind sau emiând
fotoni. Fiecare orbital avea un moment angular cuantizat, care era un multiplu întreg al unei constante fundamentale minuscule
numită H. La sfârșitul anilor 1910 și începutul anilor '20, mecanica cuantică era complet nouă — atât de nouă
încât nici măcar nu se numea mecanică cuantică. Așadar, nu toată lumea era convinsă de modelul Bohr. Un fizician
pe nume Otto Stern îl ura. A numit modelul o prostie și a mers până acolo încât a amenințat că renunță la fizică dacă Bohr ar fi
dovedit că are dreptate. Stern era atât de hotărât să dovedească greșit modelul, încât a venit cu o metodă ingenioasă de a-l testa și
l-a recrutat pe Walther Gerlach să îl ajute să proiecteze și să conducă experimentul. S-a dovedit că nu a dovedit că Bohr greșea — a sfârșit
prin a dovedi că el însuși greșea. Experimentul lor a fost atât de simplu, iar rezultatele atât de clare, încât a tranșat practic
dezbaterea: mecanica cuantică domină la scară atomică. Nu și-au dat seama la momentul respectiv,
dar experimentul lui Stern și Gerlach a găsit și dovezi concludente pentru spinul intrinsec al electronului, care era o
nouă proprietate fundamentală a naturii, esențială pentru explicarea magnetismului, a supraconductivității și a mare parte din
chimie. Astăzi îți voi arăta cum funcționează experimentul Stern-Gerlach, ce ne-am aștepta să vedem clasic
din experiment și ce au găsit Stern și Gerlach. Apoi îți voi arăta cum poți rula propriul tău experiment de tip Stern-Gerlach
cu Qiskit și un computer cuantic IBM. Ideea de bază a experimentului Stern-Gerlach
era de a găsi o metodă de a determina dacă momentul angular al unui electron dintr-un atom era cuantizat, așa cum
prezicea Bohr, sau nu, cum se aștepta Stern. Au folosit faptul că momentul angular al electronului ar cauza și existența
unui mic câmp magnetic în jurul fiecărui atom, deci îi poți vedea ca pe niște mici magneți
de tip bară. Experimentul arăta astfel: exista un cuptor plin cu atomi de argint
și un câmp magnetic cu polul Nord și polul Sud
aici. Câmpul era mai puternic în partea de sus și mai slab în partea de jos, deci producea un gradient îndreptat în sus.
În final, exista un ecran în experiment. Cuptorul încălzea atomii de argint până evaporau și apoi
zburau din cuptor cu orientarea micului magnet al fiecărui atom complet aleatorie. Apoi atomii
treceau prin câmpul magnetic. Atomii erau împinși în sus sau în jos cu o forță care depindea de direcția
polului Nord al fiecărui atom față de acest gradient de câmp. Apoi atomii loveau ecranul. Stern și Gerlach puteau privi
unde loveau atomii ecranul pentru a afla despre momentul angular al electronilor. Stern se aștepta ca atomii
din experiment să se comporte așa cum i-am descris până acum: ca niște mici magneți de tip bară care respectă
regulile fizicii clasice. Clasic, acești mici magneți atomici puteau fi orientați în orice direcție aleatorie, deci pe
măsură ce traversau câmpul magnetic puteau experimenta o gamă de forțe diferite care îi împingeau în sus sau în jos, în funcție de acele orientări. Un magnet
care indică în aceeași direcție ca gradientul ar experimenta o forță mare îndreptată în sus; în direcția opusă,
ar experimenta o forță mare îndreptată în jos; și dacă era undeva între ele, ar fi o forță mai slabă. Dacă atomul indică
perpendicular pe gradient, atunci nu ar experimenta nicio forță și ar continua drept. Din cauza acestei
game de forțe posibile, toți atomii ar trebui să lovească ecranul în puncte verticale diferite. Modelul pe care l-ar face
pe ecran ar arăta cam așa. Dar nu asta au văzut Stern și
Gerlach. În schimb, au văzut două grupuri complet separate de atomi pe ecran, fără atomi în
centru. Nu aveau teoria corectă la acel moment pentru a explica asta, dar acum știm că au văzut asta deoarece
fiecare electron are o anumită cantitate de moment angular intrinsec sub forma spinului, care poate lua numai
una din două valori. În imaginea noastră cu magneți de tip bară, asta înseamnă că există doar două orientări permise ale magneților atomici. Le numim
pe aceste două orientări spin up și spin down. Un qubit dintr-un computer cuantic
seamănă cu acest tip de sistem de spin, iar unele computere cuantice folosesc de fapt qubit-uri fabricate din spinul electronului
stări. Deci putem efectua propriul nostru experiment Stern-Gerlach cu Qiskit și qubit-urile dintr-un computer cuantic IBM. Să
mapăm starea spin up a electronului pe starea zero a qubit-ului și starea spin down pe starea unu
a qubit-ului. Când particulele de argint ieșeau din cuptor, aveau momente magnetice orientate aleatoriu. Noi
putem modela experimentul Stern-Gerlach creând un circuit simplu cu un singur qubit care începe în starea zero.
Acesta se numește diagrama circuit-ului, unde firul de sus este qubit-ul și operațiile aplicate qubit-ului
apar ca cutii pe fir. Cutiile RX și RZ sunt gate-uri cuantice care
rotesc efectiv orientarea magnetică a atomului. Putem alege valori aleatorii pentru Theta și F aici pentru a roti
qubit-ul cu o cantitate aleatorie. Aceasta imită cuptorul, care scoate atomii cu orientări de spin aleatorii. Cutia gri este
măsurarea noastră. Ne spune dacă qubit-ul este în starea zero sau unu și trimite acea măsurare la un bit clasic,
linia dublă etichetată C. Această parte este echivalentă cu măsurarea dacă atomul este în spin up sau spin down, uitându-ne la
care punct lovește ecranul. Putem folosi o primitivă Qiskit numită sampler pentru a rula experimentul de mai multe ori, fiecare cu
valori aleatorii diferite pentru Theta și f. După 100 de eșantioane, obținem o histogramă de măsurători care arată cam așa: aproximativ
50% din timp qubit-ul este măsurat ca zero și 50% din timp este în starea 1. Acesta este același rezultat pe care l-au văzut Stern
și Gerlach: este întotdeauna fie spin up, fie spin down, niciodată ceva între ele. În acest moment s-ar putea să te gândești: ei bine,
WEBVTT
bineînțeles că am obținut două rezultate discrete — am efectuat experimentul pe un computer cuantic digital, care returnează întotdeauna
zero sau unu. Și asta e adevărat, dar ține minte că motivul pentru care computerele cuantice returnează rezultate binare — de fapt,
motivul pentru care Quantum Computing funcționează deloc — este exact această cuantizare a spinului pe care Stern și Gerlach au descoperit-o primii.
Qubit-urile din computerele cuantice IBM nu se bazează pe spinuri, dar multe alte computere cuantice da, deci efectuarea unui
experiment Stern-Gerlach pe un computer cuantic ne permite să redescoperim efectiv cuantizarea spinului.
Din 1922, nenumărate extensii ale experimentului original Stern-Gerlach au fost efectuate. Aceste extensii implică
trimiterea aceluiași fascicul de atomi prin multiple aparate Stern-Gerlach pentru a vedea cum se comportă spinurile în diferite
scenarii. Iată unul: să trimitem atomii printr-un aparat pentru a separa fasciculul în două, corespunzând unui
fascicul spin up și unui fascicul spin down, și apoi să trimitem fiecare dintre acele fascicule prin propriile lor aparate
separate. Cu Qiskit, circuit-ul cuantic corespunzător acestui experiment este similar cu cel anterior, dar cu două
măsurători în loc de una. Aici am înlocuit rotațiile aleatorii care imitau efectul cuptorului cu un
gate numit Hadamard, deoarece aplicarea Hadamard ne va da aceleași probabilități de măsurare ca și cuptorul,
dar e mult mai simplu de utilizat. Deci măsurăm o dată și apoi de două ori, și
histograma de măsurători rezultată pentru experiment arată astfel, unde șirurile de biți de pe axa X corespund
rezultatelor celor două măsurători. Dacă qubit-ul a fost măsurat zero de ambele ori, asta corespunde șirului de biți 0 0, sau dacă
a fost măsurat mai întâi zero, apoi unu, asta corespunde unu zero, și așa mai departe. Se pare că dacă a fost măsurat spin up în
primul experiment, va fi spin up și în al doilea. La fel cu atomii spin down. Asta înseamnă că în primul experiment
aveam probabilitate egală de a măsura up sau down, dar până la al doilea experiment rezultatul era deja determinat. Deci cele
două ecrane de la sfârșitul fiecăruia dintre cele două aparate Stern-Gerlach ar avea fiecare un singur punct. Un ecran ar avea
toți atomii spin up și un ecran ar avea toți atomii spin down. Pentru următorul nostru experiment,
să începem cu un fascicul de atomi pur spin up. Cu un experiment fizic real Stern-Gerlach, ai putea face asta trimițând
atomii printr-un aparat Stern-Gerlach și blocând fasciculul deflectat în jos, deci toți atomii deflectați în sus sunt
spin up. Acum să trimitem acest fascicul printr-un alt aparat Stern-Gerlach, dar de data aceasta să rotim magneții cu 90°, astfel
încât gradientul de câmp să deflecteze atomii care călătoresc în această direcție spre stânga sau spre dreapta. Am vedea
un punct sau două, sau ceva complet diferit? Pentru acest experiment,
vom rula următorul circuit pe Qiskit. Vom începe în starea zero, deoarece fasciculul nostru de atomi din acest experiment sunt toți
spin up. Apoi acest gate Hadamard schimbă coordonatele x și z, astfel că are efectul de a roti
aparatul Stern-Gerlach. Deci acum măsurăm proiecția spinului spre stânga sau spre dreapta, în loc de sus sau jos. Aici obținem
histograma de măsurători care arată astfel. Deci putem vedea că spinul de-a lungul lui X poate lua și el numai două valori,
pe care le putem numi spin left și spin right. Deci acest experiment arată că dacă măsori proiecția X a unui spin
care a fost măsurat anterior ca spin up de-a lungul lui Z, va fi spin left sau right cu probabilitate egală. Să comparăm
pentru ultima oară cu așteptarea clasică, pentru a evidenția cu adevărat diferența. Clasic, ține minte că
am spus că dacă micul magnet atomic de tip bară indica perpendicular pe gradientul câmpului magnetic al aparatului,
forța asupra acelui atom ar trebui să fie zero. Nu ar trebui să fie deflectat în sus sau în jos. În acel caz, am vedea un singur punct în
mijlocul ecranului. În schimb, vedem două puncte. Deci jumătate dintre atomi au spin left și jumătate spin right, chiar
dacă anterior au fost măsurați ca up. Deci, dintr-o perspectivă a mecanicii cuantice, deși poate fi tentant să
echivalezi spin up cu un vector care indică în sus și spin down cu unul care indică în jos, nu e atât de simplu, după cum putem vedea
din ultimul experiment. Pentru a înțelege cu adevărat ce se întâmplă aici, va trebui să mergem mai adânc în subiectele
superpoziției cuantice și ale măsurătorii, care vor fi subiectul unui alt videoclip. La fel cum rămânem cu mai multe
întrebări despre cum funcționează exact mecanica cuantică, la fel s-au simțit și Stern și Gerlach. Experimentul lor nu a explicat
totul, dar a contribuit mult la stabilirea mecanicii cuantice ca esențială pentru înțelegerea lumii naturale.
A fost unul dintre cele mai importante experimente fundamentale din mecanica cuantică, care a dovedit atât cuantizarea
momentului, cât și a furnizat dovezi pentru o nouă proprietate fundamentală a naturii numită spin. Pentru a se confrunta cu adevărat și a
înțelege regulile lumii cuantice, fizicieni precum Stern și Gerlach a trebuit să se murdărească pe mâini proiectând
experimente, făcând predicții și uneori greșind. Nu există cu adevărat niciun înlocuitor pentru a încerca tu însuți lucrurile,
deci dacă vrei să încerci să rulezi câteva experimente cuantice reale, accesează modulul Stern-Gerlach
cu link în descriere. Mulțumesc că ai urmărit și ne vedem data viitoare.